en france la protection des travailleurs
indépendants examiné au sénat à partir
d'aujourd'hui un projet de loi qui est
portée par le ministre des pme alain
griset et qui fait suite au plan de
soutien aux indépendants annoncé par
emmanuel macron en septembre dernier la
réforme vise à apporter davantage de
protection et de soutien aux quelques 3
millions de travailleurs indépendants en
france on voit cela tout de suite avec
notre reporter david khalifa
[Musique]
bonjour david des travailleurs
indépendants fragilisé pendant cette
crise sanitaire beaucoup d'attentes
autour de ce projet de loi qui vise à
mieux les protéger dans un premier temps
effectivement à magali un secteur en
plein essor avant le kobe 19 mai dont lé
salaire plus aléatoire que les salariés
sous contrat ont été encore affaiblie
par la crise sanitaire le gouvernement a
donc pris la mesure de cette urgence
écouter
ils ont subi une perte moyenne de leur
chiffre d'affaires d'environ 17% soit
deux fois plus que la baisse d'activité
enregistrée en france qui a atteint 8 3%
du pib en demie
mieux les protéger c'est d'abord faire
évoluer leur statut et les garanties
qu'il offre et c'est justement sur cette
question que va se pencher le sénat est
désormais huits le projet de loi vise
tout d'abord la protection de leur
patrimoine personnel en cas de
défaillance aujourd'hui l ensemble de
leurs biens peut être saisi à
l'exception de leur résidence principale
demain seuls les éléments indispensables
à l'exercice de leur activité le seront
sans aucune formalité à un préalable
l'autre disposition forte de ce projet
de loi et l'accès à l'assurance chômage
les conditions avant était beaucoup trop
restrictive dorénavant si le projet de
loi est votée et bien elle les
travailleurs indépendants pourront
toucher une allocation chômage pendant
six mois s'il justifie à 2 ans
d'activité est au moins à 10 mille euros
de chiffre d'affaires sur l'une des deux
années et ce plan de relance à nu quand
même beaucoup de temps à se mettre en
place david pourtant c'était l'une des
promesses de campagne d'emmanuel macron
il ya presque cinq ans maintenant
effectivement et magali c'est pour cela
que les travailleurs indépendants
désormais à des doutes sur la fiabilité
de ces promesses mise en route à la fin
de ce quinquennat et surtout à l'aube
d'une élection présidentielle écoute et
on espère que ce sera pas le même effet
d'annoncé qui a été fait lors des
dernières présidentielles
lorsque le président république a
supprimé les récits pour créer une
sécurité sociale
des indépendants affiliés insécurité
sociale générale avec les mêmes
conditions donc absolument pas changé
macron a changé le nom des récits mais
c'est toujours le même dispositif et
c'est toujours quand même très difficile
pour nous donc on espère que ces
propositions donc sur augmenter parce
qu'elles seront soumis prochainement à
un vote du parlement on espère qu'elles
seront beauté
examiné par les sénateurs dans un
premier temps le projet de loi ira
ensuite au parlement pour une mise en
oeuvre en 2022 un texte portez-vous
l'habitude tout à l'heure par un
ministre des pme fragilisées par saha
mise en examen alain griset connaître en
effet le 8 décembre prochain la décision
du tribunal correctionnel de paris le
parquet a requis contre lui dix à douze
mois de prison avec sursis et trois ans
d'inéligibilité pour avoir omis de
déclarer une partie de son patrimoine
alors même s'il est présumé innocent
pour le moment c'est un boulet dont se
seraient bien passés les travailleurs
indépendants dont l'avenir est
conditionnée à part à l'adoption de
cette réforme merci beaucoup david pour
toutes ces précisions d'avis dans
laquelle ifa devant le sénat ce matin